We're going to briefly explore various modeling techniques.
But to be able to build any type of model,
we will need to first investigate the data.
We will be following the same iterative process of writing down our questions,
selecting features from the data that can best answer the questions,
build models to get some answers, and using
validation techniques to determine the model that best answer the questions.
Although we'll emphasize the process of model building,
we will still keep iterating through the Q,
M, V process, and use our diagrams to track our progress.
Before we dive into a particular example problem,
let's look at various approaches and techniques that we can use to build models.
Let's look at some of the modeling techniques in use.
One of the first techniques that comes to mind is mathematical models.
They're usually useful in domains such as natural, social or economic sciences.
The tools and concepts required to build mathematical models
involve differential and integral calculus,
differential equations, algebra, and other advanced mathematics.
The advantages of mathematical models is that they
can give generalized knowledge of systems.
They also reduce complex phenomenon to simple cases, and we can use inductive
and deductive reasoning to gain knowledge about our system and the models.
Another important technique of model building is statistical or
machine learning.
They are applicable in industry, in businesses, and
in general cases where we don't have domain-specific knowledge.
The tools and concepts required for
statistical machine learning models is a good knowledge of statistics,
machine learning, linear algebra, and some information theory.
The advantage of these models is that we can treat phenomenon in all its
complexity, and we can make inferences using computational power.
In practice, we often use a combination of mathematical modeling techniques and
statistical and machine-learning techniques.
These are applicable everywhere in science, as we mentioned, social and
economic sciences, business, engineering, as well as optimization problems.
All the tools and
concepts listed above can come in very useful to build these combination models.
The advantage is that we can use whatever model we find necessary and
as per requirement to solve our problems.
Hopefully, this table here gives you
a general idea of where we use what sort of modeling technique.
Although we're not going to cover mathematical models,
we invite you to go through the tools and concepts required, and
approach some problem with mathematical models if need be.